[Music]
welcome to waters world I'm Jessie
waters we begin with some real news you
probably didn't hear the mainstream
media report this week because all they
talked about was wacky Omarosa this is a
NOAA Moroso zone the media has already
covered our 24/7 in fact Tuesday's White
House press briefing featured nearly
four times as many questions about
Omarosa than any other topics $39.00
Rosa questions compared to just 10
questions for everything else so now
some other news Democrat keith Ellison
won the Minnesota primary Tuesday night
for the state's attorney general but
what you haven't heard is it he's been
accused of domestic abuse by his
ex-girlfriend he walked in he said I
need you to take the trash out and I
kept because I was on my stomach I heard
him and I just went like that and shook
my head and he looked at me goes hey you
hear me and then he looked at me he goes
get the [ __ ] out of my house and he
started trying to drag me off the bed
that's when I put my camera on to video
him not to be fair the congressman
denies this accusation CNN barely
covered the story at all the first two
days after the news broke
remember when abuse accusations emerged
about former White House staffer Rob
Porter a few months ago the news network
went wild dedicating an hour and 40
minutes of programming to the
allegations at versus just four minutes
and 21 seconds to the Ellison scandal
for you guys that are good at math
that's twenty four times as much
coverage of Porter than Ellison and by
the way Ellison has been seen hanging
around Louis Farrakhan he's defended a
cop killer
and he doesn't even believe in borders
this is the Deputy Chair of the DNC it
would be nice if the media would hold
him accountable to the same level they
do Republicans chili news out of New
Mexico where five people were found at
an extreme Muslim compound allegedly
training children to go into school and
teachers and police officers official
said the body of one toddler who was
abducted by the ringleader was found
buried underneath the compound and
eleven more children were being kept in
filthy dangerous conditions surrounded
by loaded rifles and handguns they were
arrested arraigned in court but despite
this judge Sarah Bachus granted them
just $20,000 bail she's a Democrat with
a history of giving very low bail at
least one of the five suspects is an
illegal immigrant Jenny a veal came here
from Haiti more than 20 years ago she's
been detained by ice you know the agency
Democrats want to abolish another Suraj
will Hajj has ties to the blind Sheikh
the mastermind behind the 1993 World
Trade Center bombing and yet another
recently returned from Saudi Arabia
where's the media been on this story
they've barely touched it I think you
guys know the answer and on Wednesday
the FBI Joint Terrorism Task Force
swarmed the Sacramento apartment and
what's being called one of the most
significant arrests of an accused Isis
terrorists in the US officials arrested
Omar Amin who according to prosecutors
was an Isis and al Qaeda hitman he's
accused of killing an Iraqi police man
while driving a pickup mounted with a
machine gun and flying an Isis flag just
a few years ago five months later he
arrived in the United States under the
Obama administration's refugee program
the same program that our former
president touted for its tough vetting
process they are subjected to the most
rigorous process conceivable the
intelligence community that's fully who
they are biometrics are applied to
determine whether they are in fact
somebody who might threaten the United
States officials say it is filled with
vulnerabilities that refugee application
was replete with lies and
misrepresentation
this is why President Trump supports the
temporary travel ban and extreme vetting
to protect America again the media will
not report this story fairly Chelsea
Clinton hitting the speech circuit last
Saturday she told a group of New Yorkers
that abortion actually helps stimulate
the economy it is not a disconnected
fact that American women entering the
labor force from 1970 to 2009 added
three and a half trillion dollars to our
economy right like the net new entrants
of women that is not disconnected from
the fact that Roe became the law of the
land in January of 1973 now think what
you want about abortion it's a very
touchy subject but stimulating the
economy is a tortured justification and
while all this crazy stuffs been
happening there was some very good news
to report the Senate confirmed two more
appellate court judges bringing the
grand total of appellate court judges
sworn in under trump 226 the highest
number for a president's first two years
in office ever youth unemployment rate
is dipped to its lowest rate in 52 years
and the u.s. is on its way to signing a
new and improved NAFTA agreement with
Mexico and the long awaited border wall
construction is progressing more than
eleven miles of the wall have been built
as of August 8th and that is your real
news of the week